[Music]
hunter's new doozy
spending his dad's cash on a floozy
what's a floozy hunter biden allegedly
spent 25 grand from an account linked to
joe biden to pay for a prostitute in
2018
that's according to the new york post
which obtained receipts and text
messages from that famous laptop that
wasn't supposed to exist
the tory transaction took place in los
angeles at the chateau marmont
which is french for chateau mormont
it's where it's where john belushi
john belushi died 39 years ago when snl
was still funny
after several drug and alcohol fueled
nights with an escort
and i don't mean ford escort cat
although they are fetching
hunter had apparently racked up a bill
over 8 000 bucks he continued charging
several accounts
thinking the payments weren't going
through which led to a whopping 25 grand
overcharge
i hate that that's when the secret
service allegedly got involved as
evidenced by these texts
from a former special agent quote come
on h
this is linked to the celtics account or
celtic could be said celtic or celtic
dc is calling me every 10. let me
let me up or come down i can't help you
if you don't
let me h for those of you playing along
at home celtic was
joe's secret service code name when he
was vice president
it's even on his medic alert bracelet
[Laughter]
so it's too bad for hunter that the
secret service can't protect you
from yourself it's like my accountant
said to me after looking at my tax
return
you can't write off secret camera in
cat's office
pete um the worst part about hunter
biden is that he gives partying a bad
name
you know what if you go out with him the
next day it's not like hey i'd like to
do that again
really yes you're right uh but he does
seem to have an unlimited credit card
his dad's card
so that's some sort of a life goal uh it
is amazing
the types of things you'd have to tell
me laura does does
this what the secret service is supposed
to do i don't even think he was under
secret server's protection which
begs a lot of different questions here
the secret service is showing up and the
answer is no
thank you yeah to save him from
overcharges to a prostitute that he was
putting on his vice presidential father
you read this entire story it's insane
every time you read something about
hunter biden it's insane by the way this
might be the only time he ever used
protection
okay i thought you're going to look at
me and say stripper like you know what
every everyone has a different job when
they start
you know this this screams of parent to
me
yes the the secret agent probably got a
call from celtic
yeah go and help me my son's doing it
again because when you're dealing with a
drug addict
who will wipe you out because he doesn't
think and he ran up every credit card he
did and of course
then he was like oh well my dad's vice
president charge him and why does he
have his dad's credit card
because he needs a couple hookers he has
a treat
i think i think he just parents have
boundaries it's just like why did that
one kid run around and knock over stuff
while my kids wouldn't dare
yeah he understands me like why don't
parents like that but this is what i was
in the first segment talking about
the progressive attack they made a deal
with a moderate
and he's common sense and he's backing
off from defunding the police
he's backing off from universal this and
get rid of this
so what all of a sudden now we couldn't
get a story when fox was covering hunter
biden
literally we don't know if it's his
laptop but now this is how we get rid of
joe because he wouldn't do what we
wanted to do
so now all of a sudden the hunter buying
stuff is coming out and now even cnn's
like
this is really hard to you know this
must be so hard for the president
now it's a problem because now the deal
the water's breaking
the civil war is going to start between
progressives and moderates because
he's not playing ball so now they're
going to go after hunter but then
they're truth seekers
when we did it we were disgusting and
attacking you
yeah and the addict's lifestyle didn't
exist the laptop
the story didn't exist so tech giants
actually buried it laura
i i imagine if this were a trump
offspring oh
i i know that's a cliched question at
this point but
i mean it has to run through your head
that like this i mean
what your family went through every day
because you're simply related
to the president and then compared to
what he's not going through
yeah it's only the daily mail that is
interested in this in the new york post
it is it's so sad actually because
whenever my father-in-law was in office
we all knew that we were a reflection of
america and we took it very seriously to
be
part of the first family of the united
states and we
wanted to act appropriately and do
things that were upstanding
to see things like this i i mean the
number of times hunter biden has broken
the law i mean he's admitted to smoking
crack i know smoking parmesan cheese
isn't
illegal just questionable but now we
know he's paying prostitutes
on possibly his father's credit card it
is outrageous stuff
it just makes me sad really for america
that
that this is a member of our first
family very sad to see you know have you
ever used your dad's credit card for
anything close to this
cat no i i no and that's why
he does have it very good right
especially for a crackhead but part of
me feels a little bad for him
because it's got to be really hard for
him to just you know have a fun weekend
if he set the bar
at getting so blasted with an escort
that you're so high you can't figure out
how to pay her when it's over
right you know like he doesn't probably
get excited for like dinner in a movie
well i mean when you're putting
[Laughter]
well it depends what's for dinner you
know it's like
broccoli steak and crack i'm sure he's
in there yes
are we watching the movie or am i in it
yeah
there you go yeah you see you go why why
watch it when you can star in it
and i mean like did you see what he did
with he you know he the things he does
with the
snacks in the mini bar what he did with
the m m's
oh my videos of all of that yes exactly
i didn't watch
any of them more than three times but
you know what he's the kind of guy that
if
that drags everybody into his problems
and if you try to help him
he guilts you like he was like man dude
why are you bothering me to this guy
this guy's trying to save you
yeah and he's being like you're just
you're basically peeing on my high
which may actually whoop improve the
high i'll be back after that
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else